and when I was growing up your boy
Daniel in my neighborhood some of you
guys know about him and some of y'all
don't and he was the kind of dude that
would you know he would uh tell you like
maybe if you were having a licorice
chunk or arm if you were having a bit of
honey candy he would tell you oh they're
poisonous they're poisonous and you'd
spit it out on the table and he would
take it and eat it
he was that kind of man he was a like he
was just second-hand sugar he didn't
carry tricky out of your own suite and
then he would polish that batch off
right in front of you and um anyway his
father had trained they had a dog
this little disgruntled little dog in
the UH this little like I don't know if
it was like a beagle or like a damn like
an Australian kind of beagle kind of
like a kind of enough like an Australian
kind of beagle sort of hound but it
would um named muscle with the dog's
name and it would they trained it to
kind of I guess kind of hump or [ __ ]
dogs other dogs at the dog park so we'd
go down there they had this kind of dog
and it wasn't really a dog park back
then when I was growing up it was just a
lot of dogs would meet up usually to eat
or to look at each other and you'd see a
dog walking by or one dog whatever you
know uh
you know he would the owner would paint
something on the side of him like a
political slogan or just all kind of
[ __ ] like an animal meet up and um and
they had their little dog a little
muscle and this thing could [ __ ] brahh
I'll be honest it's the only dog I've
ever seen that could run up behind
another dog and jump and it was real it
had long legs in the front but was a
short legged in the back and this thing
could hump like a dam
like a speed bump this thing could hump
like a [ __ ] like an extended cab
camel this thing had that up-down
up-down up-down going and it could run
and jump up into the air and land Weiner
Weiner into another animal and so this
little thing it was like the damn Robin
Hood of [ __ ] really and you'd see it
run up and just jump onto another animal
in and they had trained it to do sex so
it was just baffling man it was just
blew my mind every time we go to like
the little dog meetup and they had you
know when little muscle would show up
and this thing boy you'd see the other
owners be like aw [ __ ]
here comes a little muscle man that
little damn Bill Cosby out here this
little thing just not afraid to really
sexualize other animals but evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one